Kim Kardashian's 1.26 million dollar
Instagram fail it's a comparison that is
how much the Securities and Exchange
Commission is finding Kim for this
unlawful Instagram promo touting
cryptocurrency the reason Kim did not
disclose she was paid 250 000 for the
Post get your up and work it seems like
nobody wants to work these days in a
statement to E.T Kim's lawyer says she
quote fully cooperated from the very
beginning Kim who's worth an estimated
1.8 billion dollars also agreed not to
promote crypto for three years
and over the weekend at Paris Fashion
Week
Kanye made his modeling debut opening
Balenciaga spring 2023 show
Kim was not there but their four kids
joined Chloe and Kylie for the muddy
post-apocalyptic presentation
outside Kanye struggled to speak while
donning a Balenciaga mouth guard
that look wasn't even the wildest
Parisian fashion statement
[Music]
dojicat who sat front row at the Tom
Brown Show with Janet Jackson and Anna
winter flaunted several ensembles
including white and blue face paint but
it was Bella hadid's hand spray-on
company dress that was the most draw
dropping spectacle first Bella entered
the stage wearing just underwear and
heels then designers coated her body
with a spray-on fabric
the end look a stunning white
off-the-shoulder slip dress which closed
the show
[Applause]
[Music]